How many languages do you speak?
I speak six languages, if you include my native language,...
...but I only speak two foreign languages well.
I speak the other three languages well enough to survive,...
...but not enough for a long conversation.
I would like to improve my ability to speak them.
Perhaps in the future I'll get a job in countries where those languages are spoken.
How long have you been studying English?
I've been studying English for over ten years.
Some of that has been with teachers in the classroom...
...but I have learned a lot of idioms by listening to other people speak.
Is there anything you find especially difficult about learning English?
I find grammar quite challenging in any language.
Apart from that, it isn't that much different from other languages.
How important is English to you?
It's vital for me to know English because I use it at work every day.
I travel to English speaking countries a lot.
I also have a lot of friends from various countries...
...and we use English as a common language.
English is also really helpful for searching on the Internet.